clashes broke out at an eu border
checkpoint on tuesday when polish
security forces used water cannon and
tear gas to push back migrants trying to
cross from belarus the european union
has approved more sanctions against the
belarusian government the eu accuses
belarus of escorting potential asylum
seekers from the middle east to the
polish border
violence breaking out on the belarus
poland border
stones fly one way and water cannon
blast back
seven polish border guards were injured
one of them seriously
migrants trying to break through the
border barricade were pushed back into
belarus
water from the cannon was allegedly
laced with tear gas
in poland border guards and soldiers are
on constant watch
the operation was carried out in several
stages and the migrants had different
tasks there were people behind the front
line throwing stones and other dangerous
objects that gave the front line cover
to attempt to destroy the polish border
checkpoint
polish authorities claim the clash was
controlled and supervised by belarusian
forces
there were many people in the crowd with
face coverings that indicates that they
were belarusian security forces
in the video footage we have they appear
to be people with european facial
features and not migrants
by the evening the situation at the
border crossing had eased
according to belarus state-owned media
leader alexander lukashenko has
authorized a shelter for migrants close
to the border
dw's barbara vezel is at the poland
belarus border and she has more on the
conditions many migrants there are
facing
so they are like punching balls in this
geostrategic game between
the european union poland belarus and
russia
and they simply can't help themselves
there's just a handful of local helpers
operating in this area here they're
finding people in the forest from time
to time who are totally exhausted some
have to be taken to a hospital hospitals
because of hypothermia so their
situation is really dire and there is no
solution no political solution inside
anywhere warsaw isn't budging the
government is sticking to its hard line
nor so far do we see any great movement
on this side of minsk and
alexander lukashenko so nobody here has
really any idea and people say once it
gets really cold really really cold out
here in this forest a real human
catastrophe might happen
for more on the story we can speak to
our brussels bureau chief alexander
fornamen good morning to you alexandra i
want to ask you about uh pushbacks that
is the process of taking people who have
reached eu territory back onto non-eu
territory that is supposed to be illegal
in the eu so what does brussels have to
say about poland's actions on the border
it is illegal because every member state
is
obliged to provide admission in order to
assess individual claims for asylum
however we have to say that poland has
amended its law effectively legalizing
pushbacks and that's what also happened
to some extent in latin and lithuania in
those countries who are affected but by
their border crisis
there has been some criticism from the
european commission the commissioner in
charge said that they have question
marks that pushbacks can never
be
normalized however we have to say that
this issue doesn't seem to be a
priority for the european union for the
european commission that it seems it's
more important to sort of present a
united front against blues because it is
seen also as a geopolitical problem here
so the european union um wants uh to
show that they are not going to give in
to lukashenko and his
attempts to blackmail the european union
a geopolitical problem but are there any
signs that there's progress on diffusing
the situation on the diplomatic level
well i think that there is some movement
there we know that lukashenko was now
ready to speak with european leaders
with the german chancellor in particular
and we also know that the iraqi
government for example they have
announced a first repatriation flight
that is due to take place on thursday so
people who are willing to leave might be
able to do so
and the majority of the people trapped
there are from iraq however we also have
to say that when we look at the scenes
we just saw in the package the standoff
between the belarusian and polish border
guards at the border then
you know security forces using tear gas
and water cannon against migrants this
situation could easily escalate
at the same time you know people are
dying at the border temperatures
continue to drop i mean does the eu in
the meantime have a plan on how to bring
migrants to safety while this political
crisis
continues no i don't think so i don't
think any i don't see anything that
would amount to to a plan here
uh although we have to say that they are
there are politicians from the
german green party for example who are
saying we now need to get those people
out we need to bring them to safety and
to assess their asylum claims however
the majority don't seem to be willing to
do so because as i said they think it's
important to send a strong signal that
no one uh will believe that if they get
to belarus they will be able to get into
the european union and that's of course
a huge problem and and this is just like
a very bad situation for all those who
are now trapped between soldiers and uh
rays of wire
our brussels bureau chief alexander
fundament reporting for us thank you
very much
let's get some more perspective on this
story now we can speak to lotta light
she's the eu director of human rights
watch and she's joining us
from brussels thank you for joining us
here on dw
we have heard proposals within the
european union for example from
lithuania to create a humanitarian
quarter corridor for trapped migrants to
assist them to return to their home
countries
what do you think of that
well i think it is important to assist
those who wish to to return to their
home countries and can do so safely
at the same time there is a
responsibility on the part of eu
countries
to hear asylum claims for those who wish
to apply for asylum
and to do that in an orderly fashion
rather than meeting people with tear gas
water cannons and violence
so both would make sense and are
urgently needed apart from that what is
really
urgent right now
is for poland that has erected sort of a
state of emergency and a restricted zone
to allow immediate access to that zone
on its part of the border
to
to humanitarian organizations
journalists human rights workers and
others
lawyers who can help people with their
claims and so on this is urgent this is
now literally about saving lives well i
want to ask you about poland's
perspective here because poland says it
is protecting its borders what do you
make of that
well poland certainly has a right to
protect its borders but it also has
obligations
towards those who
are trying to enter
poland and apply for asylum
and it is clear
that what we are seeing now is a very
vicious and cynical game of illegal and
brutal pushes on the part of the belarus
authorities and security forces
and pushbacks that are also illegal and
brutal on the part of poland
two wrongs don't make a right and an eu
country should
apply its
international obligations and to treat
people with dignity and humanity is
absolutely urgent now i want to double
down on that because you have written
that belarus is indeed brutally abusing
migrants and asylum seekers in the
situation so
what is the right way for the european
union to take a stand against president
lukashenko but also seek a humane
solution
well the eu is taking a stand on
lukachenko's
ruthless manipulation of migrants
it is introducing additional targeted
sanctions and it is widening the
prospect of such sanctions to also
target those who buy into lukachenko's
very cynical game of using migrants
transporting them effectively
trafficking them to belarus and using
them as as human hostages at the border
to put pressure on the eu so that's one
part of the coin and that pressure seems
to be working now at least better than
words and threats were doing just a few
days ago because there are
some some changes and your correspondent
mentioned that before but at the same
time there is a human crisis at the
border that he that the eu and its
member states are exacerbating
by not treating migrants and asylum
seekers who are being abused
in this game
with the dignity and the rights that
they deserve
we'll have to leave it there lotta like
the eu director of human rights watch
thank you very much for joining us here
on dw
thank you